there's always a paradigm shift the way
a paradigm shift is it's like there's a
10-year period
and almost every 10-year period is the
opposite of the 10 years before the 70s
produced the 80s yeah i was amazed to
see that it bears out doesn't it and and
well the reason is
at the end of a
period of time everybody believes that
the future will be like the last 10
years right and everybody's positioned
that way so when you look at the
environment that we had over the last 10
years not inflation
no
low interest rates availability of
credit so these moves take place
typically over a period of uh 10 years
and they're let's say two legs two legs
to the move
so you have a change in mindset
people thinking what is safe
used to think that cash was safe a safe
investment
but cash doesn't it loses buying power
to inflation
so now as people realize that that loses
buying power and as the fed has to deal
with the tightening of monetary policy
you get the first leg
and that's the first leg that we're in
and when that
runs its course
which it probably would run its course i
would say in the next
18 months or so
then
you have 18 more months of of tightening
yes i mean 18 more months of
and by the way
there's nothing precise and i'm not sure
that i'm right
in this right i'm just saying i'm giving
you what i think